power rankings business and we've got
some questions
submitted via the folks at twitter let's
take a look at what we have for week 11
steelers by virtue of their blowout
victory over the bengals hold on to
number one chiefs didn't play
so they aren't moving and and you know
this was the first
tough one for me chris because the
saints don't have drew brees at least
for a week maybe longer
but when everyone who was behind the
saints loses
i can't move the saints down they won by
17 right was it 17 or so what was the
final yeah 27
10 yeah yeah i can't fault them for that
even though they're not going to have
drew brees for a few weeks they got to
stay at number three
no i i understand that you know i i do
and of course i think you can take into
last year
account you know into what happened
there to go wait no they can manage and
still be really good
without drew brees i mean last year they
went up and beat seattle in seattle with
teddy bridgewater
and not to say it was every bit as good
as the new orleans saints with drew
brees but it was good it was good enough
they're still a really good football
team
and they still look at them in a lot of
ways even though it wasn't their best
game last week
to where yeah i understand it mike i do
so i'm perfectly cool with you having
them at three
any thought at all after the discussion
we had last week or was that steelers
game just so impressive that you were
like no they're number one they're 9-0
i'm not even thinking about it
was there anything there with the chiefs
at all at one no how could you move the
chiefs to number one
they didn't play i know right and if the
team in front of them didn't lose
there's i i guess i i i'm feeling
better i remember you tried a couple of
weeks ago
to get me to have misgivings about
should the chiefs be number one
uh and and and look if if they play i
don't know if they played right now yeah
the chiefs would be favored by six and a
half points maybe
maybe five and a half neutral sight
chiefs oh i don't know what would they
be favorite i don't know and a half five
and a half
i don't know i was gonna say three and a
half but yeah i don't know maybe maybe i
don't know i don't know
but but i still think the steelers
should have a good chance to win because
that's just what they do
that's the thing whatever the opponent
they just keep winning
and eight nights from now on
thanksgiving night on nbc if they beat
the ravens the
division's over the question is can they
can they thereafter run the table
and get to 16-0 so uh i i've i feel
stronger
not weaker about the placement of
steelers at number one and i think as
the last undefeated team
the deeper and deeper you go into the
season the more and more you earn that
one number one spot yeah the idea that
this isn't college where you've got some
you know some
fluky team from the mac or from
conference usa that's undefeated and is
number five
and there's teams ahead of them with two
losses because you've got
fundamental differences between the
qualities of the programs
if you're on defeat at the nfl level
after 10 weeks
and then and there's no one else who is
you got to be the number one you just
have to be the number one team i don't
care who it is
you've got to be the number one team if
you've made it this far without losing
there's a question from
minnie smitty at what point does big ben
enter the mvp
discussion can't believe an i don't know
quarterback isn't even being mentioned
as a candidate point's bet has
been tied for fifth at plus 2500
uh look he's not he's not
dominant he's not having a huge oh my
god look at what he's doing look at his
numbers look at it
it's he's not having the kind of season
that would thrust him into that
conversation even though the team is
undefeated yeah well it's the way he's
doing it too i mean you can look at his
numbers and be a little fooled and go
boys got 22 touchdowns and four
interceptions and things like that
but we know that in some of those games
like you're saying it wasn't dominant
you know it was kind of ugly in some of
those games for two and a half quarters
and then oh it comes along and hey let's
not forget
they have a very talented wide receiver
core and he's got the luxury of
the best defense in football arguably so
i think with all those things
like i think he's right where he should
be in the discussion like
not in the main discussion but just
hanging on the outside to me that's
where he is
there's a difference to me and 22 and
four from the way big ben is playing
as compared to the 25 and one from
mahomes or the 26 and 3 for rogers
the game is predicated on them for those
two guys
the team's success it's all about hey
we're coming out with rogers and homes
and we got to do
this this and this and this helps our
team in pittsburgh it's more like
hey hey offense we'll take it slow
defense is really good you know they're
not going to get off to we'll kind of
figure it out
and we'll manage the game and once we
get a feel we'll open it up a little bit
and big
big ben will hit a few plays here and
there so to me there's a difference in
that
you know between what mahomes rogers and
russell wilson are being asked to do
which is
you know for lack of a better way to say
carry the team
on their shoulders a little bit more
than big ben just being an important
piece
and a big big puzzle here's the thing
yeah if the steelers do go 16-0 no they
have to have an mvp candidate
well that's where i you saw my podcast
clip that's where it's like you know
we're allowed to somebody on the defense
is allowed to be an mvp in football
you know but you're right it's really
yeah it's only happened twice i know
it's kind of sad i don't know what i'm
able to say it's sad to think that like
sad sad with an exclamation point sad
that kind of sad
yeah yeah what what sure what other kind
of sad is there i don't know
i don't know there's sad sad with a
period well just to think like ray lewis
and some of those years
and ed reed and troy palamalu
and those other guys they couldn't get
an nfl defense to mvp
you know that that to me i played paulo
malo and james harrison in some of those
years where they were nfl defensively
damn
they were as good as anybody i played
all year i don't care what quarterback
it was anything they were
amazing and yeah i just i'm sick of that
you know the heisman and the
nfl mvp is all about quarterback on the
best team and
screw all of you the rest of you aren't
important and i just get sick of that
well i don't know that that's what the
message is the bottom line though when
it's time to hand out these top awards
it's going to go to somebody who has
their hands on the football on a regular
basis
unless it's a year where for whatever
reason there's no dominant offensive
performance and
hey look i don't know who the defensive
player is from the st
that that's the other problem it's not
like they have one guy
right it's like every week it's someone
else it goes from cam hayward to tj watt
to bud dupree
right tamika fitzpatrick i know yeah so
i i it's it's it's going to be
very strange and i'm kind of now rooting
for it
for the steelers to go 16-0 just because
and and see the problem is they don't
unveil the mvp until the night before
the super bowl so it's not like it's
going to provide much motivation for the
steelers at that point
but the idea that that they could go
16-0 and ben would not be an mvp
candidate a serious mvp candidate is
stunning
yeah because i think if you go 16-0 the
guy who's the leader of the team
he would have to get some id just those
numbers that plus
maybe it's a go maybe here's my point
the plus 2500 maybe you want to lock
into those odds while you can
because they keep winning maybe those
odds are going to come down can we put
that up again they are going to go
and you know the one point that we
haven't made here
patrick mahomes has passed russell
wilson russell wilson had been the
odds-on favorite
all year long right mahomes
according to points bet now ahead of
wilson
it's mahomes plus 180. wilson plus 225
there's oh aaron rodgers at plus 300 why
isn't he above russell wilson that
that's what i would ask right now that's
the gap is getting
narrower and narrower and then there's
my guy red
you've got your boy blue who's it plus
2500 my guy
red is it plus 700 and
i mean that that to me is another one
that should be a little higher
uh you know kyla murray with what he's
doing
and everything there i mean you know
again we'll see we'll
evaluate as we go but again we're going
4 000 yards a thousand yard rusher
and by far the leader of the team and
the guy that makes that thing go in
arizona like
you know that's one where yeah i think
he should be more up in the mix and i
don't understand how aaron rodgers isn't
ahead of russell wilson with that
i i don't remember the facts about a
couple of facts about the steelers
before we move on oh go ahead i'm sorry
no i'm just gonna say i just don't get
that i mean
you know you can you can look at aaron
rodgers and just go hey
their running game is not special this
year he doesn't have the weapons that
that russell wilson has you know they
depend on him to win games almost every
bit as amount as russell wilson maybe
not the same way in which they do it
anymore but
that to me is where you know i think
right now after these last two weeks i
would go mahomes one
just by a smidgen over rogers who's just
leading
russell wilson that you know as of what
we've seen the last few weeks
and kyler murray i think should be right
there level right now that's russell
right yeah
couple of stats that are relevant to big
ben's candidacy first the steelers are
the 12th team in league history to score
24 or more points
in each of their first nine games of the
season and he's the quarterback
he's the guy in charge of the unit
that's scoring those points and another
stat that actually boosts roethlisberger
the steelers are the first team
since at least 1940 to win three
straight games without rushing for 50
yards in
any of those games so they're generating
points they're generating offense
with ben roethlisberger and i think at
some point he needs to rise up
also let's not forget the points the
defense set some of those up too
just you know i understand yeah okay all
right go ahead a question about the
saints from matt forest one is there a
significant difference in your mind on
where the saints rank based on who is
playing quarterback and i guess that
would be brees or jameis winston or
taysom hill
we still don't know whether it's going
to be winston or hill this weekend
against the falcons
yeah i mean yeah don't you i view the
saints as being
stronger with drew brees as not with him
but i don't know if it's enough that i
would knock them
below the packers or anything like that
i i still
have faith i do hey look i watched
jameis winston yesterday
on film it looked really good he had one
dicey throw down the middle
one but for the position he was put in
man he looks different you know you
could tell they've been on him
technique-wise
you can tell he really knows and been
caught taught about
what to look at make the decision and
fire it you know
so i i'm i'm really interested to see
what the saints will do because that
would have gave me confidence in jameis
being
able to run the offense and doing that
you know i if you made me bet mike i'm
going to say is jameis is a starter
and unlike last year we're going to see
taysom hill
infused more in his type of plays where
last year he was relegated to truly a
backup quarterback spot behind
bridgewater but that's going to be my
guess here as of wednesday another
interesting decision
came from the green bay packers who
actually moved up four spots
despite barely beating the jaguars
brandon feeling 97
packers are blowing hot and cold right
now and just sneak past
the jaguars that's hardly worth plus
four what do i know though i'm a uk fan
okay brandon philly it's a fair question
but can we pull the graphic up you have
to look at everyone who was in front of
them
everyone in front of them lost so
what do you do what do you do if the
ravens and the bills
lose and the seahawks lose and the
titans lose what do you do you gotta
move on
you gotta move the packers up yeah i you
do i i
i mean i'm not i i don't think that's
crazy that you did that also within that
we know we got to remember like no jair
alexander out there no kevin king so
they weren't exactly at like their
tip top perfect type of thing there but
that this is where i was gonna ask you
mike next
you got the packers at four all right
i don't know again and i know the ravens
didn't look good
i just don't know if i could put the
packers dolphins and cardinals in front
of the ravens quite yet
that that would be my first question in
fact lost to the last three games i know
i but they were too really good teams
you know i mean and they they they could
have lost to the colts too i know
but you know they didn't you know that
that's what i'm just doing my first
challenge to you would be i think
i would probably have the ravens and
bucks
up there either in front of the packers
or just behind them
but either way in front of the dolphins
and cardinals that's that's where
at least how i feel right now i
understand what you're doing there but
that's just my thought
hey i can't erase that memory of the
i know you're getting three losses
quickly they win monday night
in a in a spot where they've struggled
all year playing under the lights
they beat the rams monday night i'll
feel differently about it because the
rams
are are doing fairly well for themselves
i've got the the dolphins
at number five i know bill's at number
eight
and that defies yeah points bet has the
bills at minus 334 to win the division
that means you got to bet 334 to win
100.
dolphins at plus 300 bet 100 win 300 so
the clear favorite
continues to be buffalo but
i i i feel like right now miami's the
best team in the division
they're they're more complete of a
football team you know buffalo was more
it's it's it's like we talked about with
russell wilson or aaron rodgers or
holmes it's a little bit more predicated
on one guy
they attack through the passing game and
the offense that's what they do
that is the greatest thing they have and
they really don't have another
great thing on their football team you
know so i i hear you with the miami
thing miami
the defense is special it's a special
defense the scheme the personnel
he's got everything down there brian
flores and we're seeing
they don't need to like necessarily
throw for 300 yards to win games they're
they're managing the game they're
playing running the ball
to a bootlegs making a few plays here
and there
that's all they need to do and man you
look at their schedule and you just sit
here and just go
i i have a hard time thinking they're
not gonna be sitting here
at nine and three playing the chiefs in
four weeks
so i i i get it i wanna see more from
tua because we've yet to really see him
have to
oh wait you know the defense and special
teams aren't dominating
and bootlegs aren't there now you have
to play and win a game in the pocket and
do that we've yet to see that
seen some good inklings and things like
that but just get to see it that's the
last piece i'd like to see before i
start to go
man dolphins are for real watch out for
them
nfl coaches like to break their
schedules up into quarters that last
quarter of the dolphins schedule
chiefs patriots at raiders at bills but
they could be nine and three chris as
you say
entering that stretch and it could be
nine and seven it could be thirteen and
three or it could be something in
between
here's a great question from cesar
furman 15 at the beginning of last
season the talk was miami was fielding
the worst team of all time
have you ever seen a turnaround like
this one and the first team that jumps
out to me
is the 1999 race
they were four and 12. they were four
and 12 in 98
dick vermeel was on the hot seat they
they go
get trent greene to be their new
quarterback because they didn't know
what else to do
and there was a lot of hype and a lot of
hope and then trent greene
tears an acl in pre-season and
the job falls to the guy who was bagging
groceries at the piggly wiggly i know it
wasn't a piggly wiggly but i can't
remember what it was so i'll just say
piggly wiggly
and kurt warner and the rest is history
one of the great single season
performances of all time by a
quarterback by a team
the last time we had a double regular
season mvp and super bowl mvp
it was kurt warner and the rams so to me
that's as stunning as it gets
i i would say that that's the one that
came to my mind right off the bat
because that was as big a turnaround as
ever you know
i can still remember people in the nfl
at that time you know my dad was
covering the league and doing a lot of
where they were going oh
you know this rams team's got some young
talent and you were like oh they're four
and 12. yeah they're kind of fun i get
it but
can they really be that good and then
there they were that next year how about
this though just to throw one to you too
your boy red kyla murray you know man
the arizona they had the number one pick
last year
and here we are they're number six in
your power rankings so five and six have
done an
unbelievable job in flipping their team
over pete was the one that just got in
my ear to give me that little tidbit and
he's right
i mean that's right arizona's done a
damn good job but
it just shows you in the nfl no matter
where you
are if you got the right plan of attack
and find the right way to acquire assets
you can really turn your team around in
a hurry
and i mean uh it's special especially
what they've done in miami to me
that that really is a big time
turnaround and we've got the cardinals
now at number six up five spots
at the derrick quinn asks why would the
cardinals such a huge jump after winning
on a hail mary well the key word in that
question
the derek quinn is winning they won
period yeah ultimately they won they
found a way
to win the game and they played well
throughout it wasn't some flukey pull a
rabbit out of the hat they should have
lost
they should have lost they were
outplayed for 59 and a half minutes
they were good yeah right they were
behind early and they kind of controlled
the second half right yeah and and but
for that
weird larry fitzgerald moment where he's
trying to make a catch and the ball
pops up accidentally and it gets
intercepted
by jordan poyer i think it was you take
that away and i think the cardinals may
have won by 10.
driving i don't disagree they were
totally in control of the game right
there and yeah that was a weird play i
mean that was you know
we got to blame kyla murray on that too
i mean he was wide open i don't know why
he threw the ball like that but you're
right that was a moment where you went
uh
they're about to put them away here or
really put them in a tough spot and you
went oh man they're still alive here we
go
um i get you there so i don't know like
i said i don't know if i would have put
them at six but i understand it i get
that
i do now i want to ask you about a team
just a little outside the top ten
because this is another one it's it's
interesting with all these teams we got
a seven and three and six and three
holy cow the raiders at 14.
you know i just want to hear it i i
don't think you're crazy to have them
where you're 14 but
you look at them they're six and three
they beat number two and number three on
your list there
right it's just you know where where
how'd you do the juggling between the
colts the seahawks the titans the
raiders how did you kind of come to that
little spot there
i y you're suggesting i put a lot more
thought into it than i did
i i just you know so many of the teams
fell out of the top ten i think that was
part of the problem yeah
and i didn't want to drag teams that far
down and yeah i mean the raiders beat
the broncos
but the bronco like i i heard from
raiders fans who are upset that they
didn't get moved up
i don't think winning automatically
moves you up
it's not an automatic you must move up
if you win
it's part of a broader configuration
of teams rising teams falling and hey
hey as as
i said back in week three when people
were upset that the raiders weren't
higher
when they were two and 0. if you go in
to new england and beat the patriots
you'll get moved up so
sunday night if you beat
the chiefs when they come to town
you will move up that that's your
opportunity to get in the top 10. i
guarantee you
if the raiders beat the chiefs on sunday
night they will be in the top 10 when we
have this conversation next week yeah
well i would hope so i would think that
would officially because you know you
look at the schedule here we got even
their losses
are pretty damn they're good losses
let's just say that i mean it wasn't
against like crappy teams or you're like
how do they lose to that
team i don't understand it you know
they've won the games they're supposed
to
and more maybe with wins like the saints
and all that
uh they're handling their business
they're an interesting football team
because of that run game and gruden and
those things and then you know a pretty
good secondary
uh they're a team to watch out for i
mean they could be a team that
upsets some people in the afc playoffs
if they do get in
uh and and you know they're no thought
there to put bump them in front of the
titans or the seahawks or anything like
that because
you know the seahawks of course the way
they've looked the last two weeks too i
just wonder what your thoughts are yeah
but pull up the list how far down do you
penalties oh i know
i'm based on one game i i well two games
that's the
that's the well i know but but still the
seahawks were
where are they on there there they are
at number 12. titans at 13.
i just i you know i don't know that's
already five spots for the seahawks and
six for the titans to drop i i it's it's
difficult to to take them much farther
than that because at a certain point i'm
inviting a hundred emails
from people complaining about their
favorite team dropping as far as they
did
and so uh sorry raiders hey they're
still ahead of the browns
right yeah i mean if anything the browns
browns fans had but you know they had a
little black piece of wood
two weeks ago so yeah you're right to
have them all right it's a tough group
is what i'm basically saying though oh
i'm that's what i was really just
getting at
like well i like your top 10 for sure i
mean i i do i don't know if i'd have
that order
but man that colt seahawks titans
raiders little spot right there
it's hard to figure those teams out
right now
and here's the reality for the nfl this
year even though there will be 14 teams
in the playoffs there possibly will be
16 depending upon whether to what extent
the pandemic
gets in the way but if it is just 14
there's going to be some good oh my gosh
the afc
especially and remember our concern
about going to 14
that those two extra teams aren't going
to be worthy of it
it's probably not going to be this way
every year but this year
the two extra teams are going to be
worthy of it they are going to be a
tough
challenge potentially for the second
seed and i
ca i hope it's divisional matchups
in that two versus seven because i think
it makes it a tougher game for the two
seed
but uh it could be the 15 and the 16 the
next two
number eight in each conference is
capable of making noise and they're not
going to get in so
uh you know and i i'm not suggesting we
should expand
to 16 teams in the postseason i think
the nfl would like to
year in and year out but that's half the
league that's a rare i don't know that
half
i don't know that half the league
deserves to get in uh on a regular basis
maybe this year yes but not every year
no and i think also what's playing into
this a little bit
is the crappiness of some other teams is
leading to
better schedules for you know other
teams to where
yeah i don't know if some of these teams
are really six and three quality
they've maybe been fortunate to play the
nfc east or the two
crappy teams in the afc south and you
know
there's so there is some real crap out
there this year in the nfl
uh for lack of a better way to say it
that's made it yeah more top-heavy than
normal especially in the afc and i mean
you just sit here now and just go what
the six and three titans and the
the six and three cleveland browns or
the eight and nine seed right now in the
nfc
it's pretty shocking when you look at it
can we bring that
graphic up one more time of the power
rankings i have one last point that i
want to make
that that even brings into further focus
the idea that good teams are going to be
left out of the playoff field
look at the second half of
the rankings giants 24
eagles 25 washington 27
dallas 30. one of those four teams is
going to host a playoff game
and they're not even in the top 23 teams
none of them in the top 23
right now in the nfl chris it's insane
i just i just wouldn't have you know i
knew
philly i just thought they would at
least be respectable at this point
they're not even that i mean it's it's
truly
amazing where they're at in the nfc it's
gonna be so silly to see them in a home
playoff game against whoever they gotta
play
so it's not just two of those teams on
the left half of the ledger
who are gonna get bumped out three of
them yeah are gonna get bumped out yeah
because one of those playoff spots is
gonna go to a team
that does not deserve to be
in the playoff field and not just
doesn't deserve a home game doesn't
deserve to be in
and back to the point that we made a few
weeks ago i'd love to see the nfl return
to three divisions five six and five
in each conference that's what they
should do
and uh they're not going to but that's
what they should do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports